they'll try to get back in the win
column tonight when they send vince
velasquez to the mound against the miami
marlins and the 01 pitch
outward left field right at mccutcheon
and he makes the catch sticks the left
i don't think he saw it right away but
he was able to recover right away
phillies have to take advantage of it
pop-up outside of first hoskins hustling
over and is there to make the catch what
a play
able to brace himself as he went into
the railing
two outs here in the first inning
trevor rogers back again and he brings a
208 era into the ball game tonight he
has been spectacular all season long
people don't remember earl campbell look
him up
that one hit him on the elbow so he's
aboard well teams just don't slug
against him this year
strikes out real muto approaches box
and there's ball four so harper walks
that puts runners on first and second
with two men down so two men on a hit
batter and a walk that'll bring up
andrew mccutchen
broken that looper out toward left field
that's gonna drop in for a hit here
comes segora heading home the throw to
the plate is not in time it's cut off by
the pitcher and the phillies take a
one-nothing lead
[Music]
[Applause]
that one tapped to rogers who's going to
have to take it himself and he gets
there just in time a head first slide
attempt by hoskins
but rogers just beat him to the bag
the 3-2 pitch
and a call strike three
two outs here in the second
birdie's got uh much more speed
and he can get some hits too we know
that this one's gonna head toward the
gap but cut off by harper and birdie
with yet another base hit
bertie stays put on the one-two pitch
that hops away from rio muto goes way up
into the air and birdie is on his way to
second there easily
and a fastball and a call strike three
two strikeouts of the inning
for vince velasquez
[Applause]
and boehm takes low
that's the second walk issued by rogers
and velasquez buttons up the first base
side that's good bud he's going to get
bulb over to second
cuts and misses rogers gets the
strikeout his second of the game
let's see if we see it with jazz
jazz up the middle that's going to be a
base hit
now hopefully working his way out of
what was a couple of weeks slump or so
out to right field that's well hit
harper's going back toward the wall he
has room he jumps and he makes the catch
a step or so from the warning track from
the scoreboard
and the side is retired
ahead of segura 0-2 gets him to chase
another one in the dirt
0-2
and that time it's a fastball up and out
of the zone rogers with a couple of k's
in the third
high end velocity
he went after him but on the low end of
the strike zone
inside ball four that's a good fight for
malafoam two two-out walk
it's the third walk issue tonight
[Applause]
fly ball right field
duvall puts it away rogers threw four
innings he's giving up one run
nothing philly's
swing at a foul tip he got him three
strikeouts for velasquez
tried to check did he go yes he did
velasquez is hauling in all the mail so
far this inning
and trevor delivers swinging a miss
strike three
you can add two or three balls and two
strikes here it comes to segura
just missed blowing in you better get it
well rogers gets another strikeout 95 up
and out of the zone
swig of the best
strikeout for velasquez that's his fifth
he's retired nine in a row at the 2-2
pitch swing and a miss
he got him
strikeout number six
vince velasquez leaving marte feeling
rejected
again a 3-2 pitch
and that one tipped into the glove so
strikeout number eight
purple row that's about i believe about
halfway up that last deck
so
bring up rhys hoskins
that one is drilled deep to left field
[Applause]
a solo home run for reese hoskins that
little guy's got a souvenir he can take
home with him it ends at old for 23. it
gives the phillies a two-nothing lead
and he buried it
another change-up by rogers is just
hung over the center of the plate and
man
the phillies needed it but he needed it
too badly
and rogers this night is done
anthony bender into the ball game his
22nd of the year
[Applause]
same spot different pitch bender gets
the strikeout
[Applause]
swinging a miss he got him to go fishing
seven strikeouts for vince addition of a
fly ball out
ground ball toward the middle tyrese is
up with it throws to first in time 6-3
on the put out eight pitches seven
strikes
13 in a row retired by velasquez
say he's done his job at seven innings
pitches outside
and brad miller draws a walk
that one gets away from alfaro and
miller scampers up to second base
so odubal herrera who's got really good
numbers lifetime as a pinch hitter
flip it past the third baseman down that
line
right center field marty is on the road
he's not going to get there it's off the
scoreboard
miller will score oh double herrera
pulls into second base
[Music]
it's three-nothing phillies
[Music]
a timely deuce from module herrera all
the issues the phillies have had with
the bullpen
and they've been vast as that one gets
away from alfaro and takes a
a lollipop hop back to him enables
herrera to scamper to third
whoa it's off the glove of alfaro here
comes herrera he's gonna score
the phillies are in rhythm for two in
the sitting
and the 3-0
outside ball four and the inning
continues
yep here comes don mattingly that's
going to be it for bender
he's given up his first two runs of the
season
what an amazing run for him
but the phillies have got him for two
and a fly ball out to left field sanchez
waits for it to come down
he'll make the catch
let's see
birdie draws the walk as he is aboard
for the second time tonight
throwdown to second is not in time
bounces away from segura but a stolen
base for john bertie
swing and a miss hung on two yeah tip
swinging a tip hung onto by real muto
they have the pitch coming
swing gonna miss
way out in front of that changeup
work to be done in this one three and
two and the marlins get another base
runner
runners go on 3-2 and it's low for ball
four they're loaded for starling marte
i'm sure intently in the on deck circle
that gets away from real muto and bertie
is going to come in to score
the pitch from alvarado
and back towards shortstop on a couple
of hops terres is up with the throws to
first in time
and the inning is over
[Applause]
102
is slowly rolled to third aguilar bare
hand look at that it's brooks robinson
over there ladies and gentlemen what a
play by jesus aguilar
and a ground ball up the middle of base
hit the man does it all
duvall fly ball center field back goes
herrera goodbye homerun
adam duvall a two-run shot the marlins
are down a run
three balls and two strikes again to al
faro and the pitch from alvarado swing
and a miss
hold on we're coming in for a landing
the phillies bullpen has closed it out
a one-run victory
he did try the cutter